- [Instructor] Erin was asked to find
if f of x is equal to x squared
minus one to the 2/3 power
has a relative maximum.
This is her solution.
And then they give us her steps,
and at the end they say,
is Erin's work correct?
If not, what's her mistake?
So pause this video
and see if you can figure it out yourself.
Is Erin correct or did she make a mistake
and where was that mistake?
Alright now let's just do it together.
So she says that this is the derivative.
I'm just going to
reevaluate here to the right
of her work.
So let's see, f prime
of x is just going to be
the chain rule.
I'm gonna take the
derivative of the outside
with respect to the inside,
so this is going to be 2/3 times
x squared minus one to the
2/3 minus one, so the negative 1/3 power,
times the derivative of the inside
with respect to x.
So derivative of x squared
minus one with respect to x
is two x. (fire truck ringing)
There's a fire hydrant, fire,
not a hydrant.
That'd be a noisy hydrant,
there's a fire truck outside.
But okay I think it's passed.
But this looks like what
she got for the derivative
because if you multiply two times two x,
you do indeed get four x.
You have this three right
over here in the denominator,
and x squared minus one
to the negative 1/3,
that's the same thing
as x squared minus one
to the 1/3 in the denominator,
which is the same thing as the cube root
of x squared minus one.
So all of this is looking good.
That is indeed the derivative.
Step two, the critical
point is x equals zero.
So let's see,
a critical point is where
our first derivative
is either equal to zero
or it is undefined.
And so it does indeed seem
that f prime of zero is
going to be four times zero,
is going to be zero over three times
the cube root of zero
minus one, of negative one,
and so this is three times negative one,
or zero over negative three,
so this is indeed equal to zero.
So this is true.
A critical point is at x equals zero,
but a question is, is this
the only critical point?
Well a critical point as we mentioned
is where the function equals zero
or where it is undefined.
And this is the only one where
the function equals zero,
but can you find some
x-values where the function
is undefined?
Well what if we make the derivative,
what would make the
denominator of the derivative
equal to zero?
Well if x squared minus
one is equal to zero,
you take the cube root of zero,
you're gonna get zero in the denominator.
So what would make x squared
minus one equal to zero?
Well x is equal to plus or minus one,
these are also critical
points because they make
f prime of x undefined.
So I'm not feeling good about step two.
It is true that a critical
point is x equals zero,
but it is not the only critical point.
So I would put that there.
And the reason why it's important,
you know you might say well,
what's the harm in not noticing
these other critical points?
She identified one,
maybe this is the relative maximum point.
But as we talk about in other videos,
in order to use the first
derivative test so to speak
and find this place where
the first derivative is zero,
in order to test whether it is a maximum
or a minimum point is
you have to sample values
on either side of it to make
sure that you have a change,
a change in sign of the derivative.
But you have to make sure that
when you test on either side
that you're not going beyond
another critical point
because critical points
are places where you can
change direction.
And so let's see what
she does in step three
right over here.
Well it is indeed in step
three that she's testing,
she's trying to test values on either side
of the critical point that she,
that the one critical
point that she identified.
But the problem here,
the reason why this is a little shady,
is this is beyond another critical point
that is less than zero,
and this is beyond, this is greater than,
another critical point
that is greater than zero.
This is larger than
the critical point one,
and this is less than the
critical point negative one.
What she should've tried is x equals 0.5
and x equals negative 0.5.
So this is what she shoulda done is try
maybe negative two,
negative one,
negative 1/2, zero,
1/2, and then
one, we know is undefined,
and then positive two.
Because this is a candidate critical,
a candidate extremum,
this is a candidate extremum,
and this is a candidate
extremum right over here.
And so you wanna see in
which of these situations
you have a sign change of the derivative,
and you just wanna test in the intervals
between the extremum points.
So I would say that really
the main mistake she made
is in step two,
is not identifying all
of the critical points.